i pretty much had an image in my mind
that most people in the world are jewish
and most jews are ultra orthodox
when i was 19 was the first time i got
access to internet and i was like okay i
have to check
i found the like hebrew wikipedia page
about trans people
i couldn't read english at that point i
was only able to read in hebrew
my life was never the same after that
i'm abby stein i was raised in the
hasidic community in williamsburg
brooklyn new york i identify as a woman
of trans experience
the
community in williamsburg is probably
one of the most sheltered communities
definitely in the u.s perhaps even in
the world
everything is different
i was raised without internet tv movies
broadway shows music magazines
i couldn't have a conversation in
english until i was 20.
in the consider community men shaved
their head i hated that i had to shave i
would have loved to have long hair
now it's just as different as it gets at
least in terms of like facial hair like
anything like that
growing up i always identify
more
with the
feminine part with the females in my
family and my community
every time that i try to tell myself
it's not that you're a girl something
else is a problem
i would start battling with depression
and
got to a point where i realized hey this
is not a life i have to do something
when i left the community i was raised
in i didn't know how to dress or have to
talk to people and i have to figure out
everything from scratch and in some ways
that's exactly what i'm doing now in
terms of transition on the gender
spectrum
people tell me a lot oh you're so brave
you're so strong and i always feel like
i don't know i only did what i have to
do to survive
and if there's one thing that i could go
back and tell myself when i was six
years old 12 years old it's no dear
other people like you
you